[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france24 una
histórica sentencia de la corte
constitucional de colombia ordenó
mejorar el sistema de protección a
víctimas de trata en el país la decisión
se tomó basada en el caso de yolanda una
mujer venezolana que padeció este crimen
y que finalmente obtuvo algo de justicia
yolanda no habían sido adecuadamente
identificada como una víctima de trata
ni protegida por las autoridades
colombianas pero ahora la corté ampara
sus derechos y a su familia esto no solo
cobijará a otras mujeres en su situación
sino que además supone un importante
precedente a nivel regional al ser la
primera decisión judicial en pro de los
derechos humanos de una migrante caída
en una red de tráfico de personas
la historia de quien llamamos yolanda
para proteger su identidad sucedió en
2019 cuando fue engañada con una promesa
de trabajo como vendedora de café en
colombia tras llegar al país fue
amenazada para ser explotadas
sexualmente al igual que sus hijas de 6
y 7 años aunque logró escapar o no
encontró refugio en las autoridades y no
ha tenido acceso a vivienda adecuada a
servicios de salud mentales física o
tampoco a empleo además ella y su
familia se han enfrentado a varias
amenazas veamos
nosotros
conocíamos una vecina
pues estuvo acá en colombia y ella dijo
que le había ido muy bien
y ella nos ofreció trabajo
para acá para colombia
yo le dije en los momentos que hablo con
nosotros que no que no sabía si venir o
no porque yo tengo mis hijos y entonces
ella dijo que no me preocupara que yo me
los podía traer pues yo me traje a mis
dos niñas y nunca pensé que ella fuera
de ese tipo de personas y resulta que
cuando llegamos acá no era lo que ella
nos había dicho era otra cosa
y ella me dice no tú no vienen a
trabajar vendiendo tintos tú vienes y
vas a trabajar de prostituta y tu hija
de 8 años ya tiene clientes porque ella
se tiene que acostar con personas
mayores que le gustan estar con niñas
menores de edad
y yo les dije que no ellas son mucho
agarrar un cuchillo y yo me puse muy
nerviosa entonces mi esposo le dijo que
se calmara que esa no era la forma que
nos explicara que era lo que iba a
suceder porque nosotros veníamos a
trabajar no de esa manera que ella me
estaba comentando y que como iba yo a la
niña
a trabajar de eso sino ella es una niña
el señor después que mi esposo se va él
entra al cuarto con un cuchillo y el
señor me lo pone en el cuello y me dice
que me quedara quietecita porque estaban
las niñas y que si yo no abría las
piernas él podría atentar contra la vida
de ellas y contra mí y él quiso abusar
de mi hija que tiene 8
y fue donde yo reaccioné
y lo empuje
y pudiera agarrar lo poquito que tenía
que era un solo bolso y bajé las
escaleras y aproveché que la puerta
estaba abierta y salí y me fui a un
parque cercano donde a mí me caí
[Música]
vamos a conversar sobre el tema y por
eso está en ella soy maría cecilia
ibáñez abogada de women's link worldwide
y la organización sin ánimo de lucro que
adelanta la defensa de yolanda varias de
cilia bienvenida y después de ver este
testimonio cuando yolanda logró escapar
inició un proceso con fiscalía pero no
solamente no le creyeron sino que
también le dijeron que eso no era
tráfico humano sino inducción a la
prostitución cuál es la diferencia y por
qué ese concepto errado la dejó
desprotegida con su familia
bueno muchísimas gracias muchas gracias
por la invitación a women schlink si
entonces lo que ocurrió en el caso
yolanda es que la fiscalía determinó que
el delito por el cual iba investigar los
hechos era inducción a la prostitución y
no trata de personas digamos que los
delitos configuran hechos completamente
distintos y además la implicación es que
las víctimas de trata de personas tienen
derecho a ciertas medidas de protección
y asistencia según el marco legal
colombiano pero en el momento en que la
fiscalía decide que este no es el delito
por el cual va a investigar los hechos
la secretaria de gobierno de la alcaldía
de la ciudad donde se encontraba yolanda
concluye que entonces definitivamente
yolanda no era una víctima de trata de
personas y por este motivo no ordena las
medidas correspondientes de protección y
de asistencia sin embargo esto es muy
particular y es bastante digamos es un
caso que se que se repite constantemente
y es muy problemático porque en realidad
como dijo la corte constitucional en la
decisión de yolanda nunca la protección
y la asistencia deben estar supeditadas
a lo que ocurra en el proceso penal por
el contrario las autoridades como la
secretaria de gobierno de cúcuta
implementar un enfoque de derechos
humanos y proteger a las víctimas de
trata y como se dice eso no está pasando
y más preocupante aún en pandemia
aumentó la migración de mujeres y de
niñas que están cada vez más expuestas a
diferentes tipos de violencia incluyendo
la violencia sexual seguimos siendo las
mujeres la mayoría de víctimas de trata
porque esta sentencia es tan relevante
para toda la región
exacto la sentencia también es muy
relevante porque la corte constitucional
reconoce expresamente que la población
migrante venezolana enfrenta una
situación particular de riesgo porque
han sufrido distintas formas de abandono
estatal se encuentran en situación de
pobreza extrema y además se ven forzados
a emigrar en condiciones migratorias
irregulares entonces digamos toda la
población migrante venezolana enfrenta
una situación particular de
vulnerabilidad pero además como lo
reconoce la corte constitucional las
mujeres migrantes aún más porque
precisamente confluyen dos factores
históricos de discriminación como lo son
el género y la condición migratoria y
esto hace que las mujeres y las niñas
migrantes venezolanas que se encuentran
saliendo de venezuela actualmente por la
emergencia humanitaria compleja que
enfrenta este país estén en una mayor
situación de peligro
qué ha pasado en el caso particular de
yolanda tuvo acceso a atención física
tuvo acceso a atención psicológica tiene
una casa en venezuela estado en colombia
hasta el momento yolanda y su familia
permanecen en una situación muy grave de
vulnerabilidad no tienen acceso a
alojamiento no tienen acceso a salud no
tienen acceso a alimentación ni a las
condiciones mínimas de subsistencia
incluso en agosto de 2020 por solicitud
de women sling la corte constitucional
ordenó unas medidas provisionales de
protección para yolanda y su familia
pero las autoridades correspondientes no
han cumplido con ellas entonces en este
momento ellos permanecen en situación de
desprotección hasta que no se cumpla con
las órdenes de la corte constitucional
bueno y cuánto tiempo podríamos o
tendríamos que esperar para que se
cumplan las órdenes de la corte
constitucional y mientras tanto quien le
está ayudando
la corte da un tiempo un tiempo de
cumplimiento a cada una de las entidades
a partir de la notificación de la
sentencia y a partir de ahí hay que
monitorear con las entidades que en
efecto van a cumplir con este término
mientras tanto yolanda continúa digamos
recibiendo el apoyo de the women clean
bueno este caso nos muestra
definitivamente una realidad que es
apabullante pero sobre todo es muy
entristecedor que nos muestra como los
sistemas de justicia siguen sin estar
pensados para proteger a las mujeres
siguen estando en contra de los derechos
humanos de las mujeres nos falta
entonces que política feminista
educación en derechos humanos que es lo
que necesitamos para que haya un cambio
de fondo en sistemas como el sistema de
justicia colombiano
bueno en realidad este caso demuestra
sin ninguna duda el poder que tienen los
sistemas de justicia de lograr la
protección de los derechos de las
mujeres desde women's link celebramos
muchísimo esta decisión y consideramos
que definitivamente
demuestra también el compromiso de la
corte constitucional colombiana con los
derechos de las mujeres ahora lo que hay
que hacer es verificar el garantizar que
las autoridades involucradas en este
caso cumplan con las órdenes de la corte
constitucional claro pero es que este
caso sucedió en el año 2019 ella pidió
ayuda con prontitud y estamos ya
finalizando el 2021 y todavía no se le
han respetado
sus derechos humanos entonces en el
papel están escritos la orden está dada
pero la aplicación como siempre y
especialmente en los países
latinoamericanos es supremamente difícil
y jamás jamás no sólo no tienen en
cuenta un enfoque de género sino que
tampoco tienen en cuenta un enfoque de
derechos humanos que es lo que usted nos
decía al principio de esta entrevista
de acuerdo es un proceso paulatino pero
definitivamente sentencias históricas
como ésta contribuyen a que
eventualmente los sistemas de justicia y
también los sistemas administrativos en
todos los países continúen y empiezan a
implementar un verdadero enfoque de
género a derechos humanos en todas las
cuestiones a las que se enfrenten de
hecho está esta sentencia es histórica
en colombia pero por supuesto como dices
tú también es un referente muy
importante en la región particularmente
teniendo en cuenta que la migración
venezolana que se ha dado en razón de la
emergencia humanitaria compleja que se
enfrenta en venezuela y también a raíz
de la pandemia generada por el coi 19
pues quiere decir que muchos países de
la región están actualmente enfrentando
problemas similares entonces esta
sentencia sirve como ejemplo para que en
todos estos países también implementen
en mayor medida un enfoque de derechos
humanos para atender a las víctimas de
trata de personas y también un enfoque
de género bueno ya en varias
oportunidades he conversado yo con
representantes de women sling y ustedes
se caracterizan por brindar protección a
mujeres en situaciones bien complicadas
y en lograr algunos casos de éxito para
que sus derechos sean restituidos que me
podría decir usted acerca de cómo está
en este momento la situación no solo de
inmigración sino de tráfico humano que
pues tiene cifras altísimas
especialmente en américa latina'
bueno un problema grande en materia de
trata de personas es que por lo general
las cifras van a ser muy difíciles de
obtener las personas tienen muchísimo
miedo de denunciar especialmente porque
están en una situación de vulnerabilidad
muchas de ellas ni siquiera saben que
fueron víctimas de trata de personas y
además precisamente porque está
relacionado todo esto con el contexto
migratorio quiere decir que muchas de
estas personas se han visto emigrar se
han visto forzadas a emigrar en
condiciones migratorias irregulares
entonces en el momento en que se acercan
a las autoridades tienen miedo que las
vean es como personas en situación
migratoria irregular no como víctimas y
simplemente se tomen las medidas que no
son correspondientes entonces la
situación tenemos conocimiento que es
muy grave en los contextos migratorios
exacerban la trata de personas sin
embargo el tema con las cifras es
complejo precisamente porque muchas
personas tienen miedo de denunciar y
precisamente una de las fallas grandes
de los estados incluyendo colombia es
que no tienen
no tienen en su política pública unos
procedimientos adecuados para
identificar adecuadamente a las víctimas
de trata y precisamente la sentencia a
la corte constitucional en el caso de
yolanda es muy buena porque ordena al
ministerio del interior colombiano
desarrollar un protocolo para
adecuadamente identificar a las víctimas
de trata y esperamos que efectivamente
así sea gracias a usted de maría cecilia
de ibáñez abogada de women's link de por
estar con nosotros para el análisis y
esta radiografía de lo que sucede con
las mujeres migrantes y con el tráfico
humano gracias a usted y a nuestros
televidentes sigan en france24 nos vemos
próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]